il faut qu'on réalise tout le monde à
quel point on a un chantier qui est
écologique économique technologique
sociale politique et c'est gigantesques
ça va nous demander beaucoup de
persévérance beaucoup de détermination
beaucoup d'inventivité mais c'est un
projet tellement emballant pour
embarquer François
qu'il nourrit pour son second mandat et
vaste menu dans lequel l'environnement
prend plus de place que durant ces
quatre premières années au pouvoir que
faut-il retenir de ce début de petite
sessions à Québec il faut y avoir ce
campement mes collaborateurs elle est
casse languette animateur de midi info à
ici première Chantal Hébert et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et au
magazine L'actualité et Michel serrurger
et chroniqueur politique à la presse
plus et Radio-Canada bonjour à vous
trois
bonjour alors avec qu'est-ce que l'on
retient de ce long discours d'ouverture
de monsieur Legault cette semaine une
heure 17 minutes je crois qu'est-ce que
vous avez retenu
[Musique]
il était long mais il y a clairement
deux aspects qui ressortent de son
discours parce que il a beau dire que
l'éducation reste sa première priorité
c'est celle dont il a parlé le moins
longtemps c'est vraiment son discours et
en matière d'économie et de santé on
était dans le réchauffé on avait déjà
entendu assez souvent les lignes pour la
réforme en santé rattraper les coeurs de
richesse avec l'Ontario il y avait un
peu de fraîcheur c'est donc ce qu'on a
retenu c'est-à-dire la transition
énergétique comme on peut créer des
emplois avec les technologies vertes
peut-être capable de décarboner le
Québec et la langue qui passe beaucoup
par l'immigration francophone ça aussi
c'est nouveau volte-face complète du
gouvernement qui ne veut plus maintenant
tant rapatrier des pouvoirs à Ottawa
notamment la réunification familiale que
de se concentrer sur ses on va pouvoir
mais de bien les utiliser ça c'est un
changement de câble donc transition
verte environnement donc oui mais aussi
immigration c'est ce qui a retenu
l'attention et c'est ce qui étant donné
qui est plus nouveau on le sentait aussi
chez le Premier ministre cette espèce
d'emballement cette excitation là de
parler de quelque chose qui est
peut-être un petit peu plus frais même
si le parler de beaucoup beaucoup de
choses en une heure 18 j'ai vu j'ai vu
Chantal dans les épaules ont sauté
qu'est-ce que vous avez senti vous chez
le Premier ministre mais que c'est
toujours plus agréable de manger de la
baguette fraîche que ça fait on a sorti
du congélateur après quelques mois donc
oui
c'est la réponse après quatre ans de la
coalition à venir Québec à la quadrature
du cercle sur la transition verte c'est
à dire on a trouvé une façon d'allumer
des ambitions économiques au dossier de
la transition énergétique ce qui est pas
une mauvaise chose je suis pas sûr que
Monsieur Lego va trouver ça aussi frais
il va peut-être un jour assisté c'est
pas comme premier ministre à l'ouverture
d'un barrage d'un nouveau barrage dans
15 ans mais c'est sûr que c'est un
dossier sur lequel le gouvernement en
intention de plancher celui de
l'hydroélectricité et de l'allumage des
ambitions du Québec à la réalité de la
production sur lequel les planchez pas
de façon aussi intense ou il n'y avait
pas conçu de le faire il y a 4 ans
de rester au pouvoir longtemps s'il veut
inaugurer le prochain barrage au Québec
par exemple
oui d'autant que quand tu dis 15 ans
c'est peut-être un peu optimiste
autochtones d'une part puis avec des
choses comme le bac alors ça m'a plu ça
et surtout Hydro-Québec est pas très
convaincu qu'il fallait un nouveau
barrage juste un léger de détails mais
que monsieur Legault a oublié de dire
mais c'est quand même le cas alors toute
sa transition énergétique qui existe
encore malgré un troisième bien malgré
toutes sortes de choses reste
jusqu'à preuve du contraire un plan et
pas une réalité et puis l'espèce de plan
où personne va devoir se serrer la
ceinture d'aucune façon puis il y aura
pas de il y a pas de sacrifice qui va
être demandé quand on voyait monsieur
fait diabète
en journée mais l'allumer juste le soir
et cetera et cetera il y a des distances
même au sein même du cabinet il y en a
aussi son immigration
même si là on voit que Monsieur Lebeau a
cessé de demander le pouvoir sur la
réunification familiale parce que ça
être obligé de faire exactement la même
chose que ce qu'elle fait le fédéral et
maintenant on parle du chemin Roxane ce
qui va être très populaire et dit bien
sûr ben on va contrôler entre
immigration et aller chercher 100% de
francophones ce qui est plus facile dit
que faire parce que ça fait très
longtemps que le Québec essaie de voir
le plus grand nombre des migrants
francophones possibles et très loin de
200 % changement c'est vrai que ça c'est
un changement de temps en immigration là
parce que il était très revendicateur
durant la campagne électorale puis là ça
s'est considérablement adouci qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
j'ai l'impression que quand un moment
donné on peut dire que je vois un mur
mais le mur va s'effacer devant moi si
je continue à foncer puis là on arrive à
côté du mur de juste
et
tous ces appels sur l'immigration y
compris pendant campagne électorale
fédérale votez pas pour Justin Trudeau
l'avenir de la nation est en cause etc
ça a pas eu de la résonance qui l'aurait
voulu donc de s'en aller sur un autre
chemin qui sur lequel il y a plus de
contrôle d'une part et d'autre part
qu'il met davantage
théoriquement sur la même longueur
d'onde que le gouvernement Justin
Trudeau c'est probablement un plus
payant et deux oui c'est vrai que c'est
plus vite dit que fait mais c'est quand
même beaucoup plus réaliste et beaucoup
plus pratique au pratique comme objectif
que l'objectif de dire si seulement
contrôlé toutes les grandes mamans qui
pourraient venir rejoindre leur famille
en s'assurant qu'elle prime des cours de
français avant d'agriver tout irait bien
ça tenait pas vraiment la route Alex
j'ai envie de vous entendre sur le côté
environnemental on s'entretain avec le
ministre charrette un peu plus tôt dans
l'émission on a l'impression que le
gouvernement a compris le message du
premier mandat qu'on avait négligé
considérablement ce dossier là puis que
là on essaie de le ramener un peu à
l'avant-plan qu'est-ce que vous en avez
compris
mais ça fait un moment qu'on dit qu'on a
compris le message souvenez-vous après
la première élection 2018 François LEGO
a fait son mec ou le Panzer j'aurais dû
parler davantage d'environnement je vais
venir tarder pendant mon mandat et de
fait il a parlé d'environnement il y a
des sites de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre la moitié du plan et peut-être
pas complet mais au moins la moitié elle
est là etc on a parlé de consigne on a
parlé de fond bleu donc de qualité de
l'eau des rivières la difficulté puis
Michel le dit un petit peu la difficulté
c'est tout ce qui est environnement
économique ça va bien tout ce qui est
énergie environnement ça va c'est quand
on arrive dans les contraintes et ça va
en prendre des contraintes pour que les
gens modifient leurs habitudes faudra y
arriver un jour à ce bonus malus ou
faudra taxer les voitures énergivores
encourager davantage les voitures de
petits gabarit les taxes kilométriques
tout le tout ça se réfléchit partout
dans le monde et c'est quand on arrive à
imposer même un petit contrainte aux
citoyens pour leur dire là ça prend les
forces supplémentaires ou le
gouvernement vraiment pas le goût
vraiment pas le vous allez là alors à un
moment donné on a bien beau parler de
développement économique de filière
batterie d'électrification des
transports mais ça va prendre un certain
moment un peu un petit peu de bâton et
là on a rien rien entendu de ce côté-là
du côté du gouvernement
qui était pas question de bâton dans la
bouche en discours de Monsieur Charlotte
et il allait pas dans ses élections là
un autre parti qu'on a pas vu au Salon
bleu cette semaine Michel les trois
députés pékistes sont décidés
persistait et signait ils sont pas
rentrés ils ont pas prêté le serment au
souverain qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette de cette
enquête là utilisons le temps en temps
les pékistes n'ont pas gagné de victoire
depuis très longtemps et même pas de
victoire morale et ça c'était une façon
de donner une victoire morale au troupes
pékistes qui avait vraiment besoin d'en
avoir une on a vu d'ailleurs que les
pékistes sur les réseaux sociaux hier
député là-dessus la réalité c'est aussi
que dans le reste de la population ça a
pas fait exactement le genre de réaction
qui qui qu'ils auraient souhaité
bon le serment au roi va être aboli oui
mais avec le projet de loi d'un autre
parti et pas du leur aurait pu être là
pour voter le patron pas et d'autre part
ils ont aussi provoqué un malaise chez
certains pékistes en disant écoutez
c'est on ne peut pas prêter serment au
roi sinon on va se parjurer
national depuis 1970 l'emprunté le
serment
néanmoins ça a dû faire quand même assez
de baguettes dans l'opinion publique et
je suis pas en train de dire que les
gens auraient marché dans la rue sur ce
sujet là pour que le Parti libéral du
jour au lendemain
on va fouter plein de questions et on va
s'assurer que ça marche et se réveille
le lendemain matin il convertit à l'idée
que le serment était désuet et moi j'ai
trouvé que l'épisode en révélé autant
sur l'état du Parti libéral que ça la
stratégie du Parti québécois là-dessus
dans le sens où on dirait qu'il se voit
pas aller et qu'il faut toujours qu'ils
aillent dormir une nuit pour se rendre
compte que là il sent aligné pour être
le parti qui se présentait à l'Assemblée
nationale et dont la première grosse
bataille ça allait être de sauver du
serment au roi ou de s'assurer que
c'était possible de s'en débarrasser
alors qu'au sein de la population
anglophone anglo-canadienne même à
l'extérieur du Québec la majorité trouve
que cette idée de serment est désuète
québécois se retrouvait dans une
situation où ils ont besoin de faire des
coups d'éclats pour montrer qu'ils
existent et attirer l'attention c'est
quand même ironique c'était deux parties
qui avaient l'habitude de s'échanger le
pouvoir et il se retrouve un peu comme
Québec solidaire à l'époque
souvenez-vous quand Mercadier là on sait
des souliers sur les portraits de
Georges Bush puis tourner le dos à la
Présidence de l'Assemblée non mais c'est
ça ils étaient deux ils étaient trois
avaient besoin d'attirer l'attention
pour être capable de plaider leurs
points mais on se retrouve dans cette
situation là autant au PQ qu'au partis
libérale parce que ça va mal parce qu'il
faut être capable de et là on cherche
d'une manière ou d'une autre
le filon pour être capable d'attirer
l'attention vous aurez remarqué qu'à la
coalition de Québec à Québec solidaire
on est moins dans cette philosophie là
d'une inversion des rôles parce que la
capucie a déjà joué dans
une inversion des rôles assez savoureuse
qu'on regarde avec un peu de recul on
pense une question qui intéresse un
parti souverainiste à Québec à un
gouvernement en Alberta qui se donne des
allures souverainissent écoutez ce qu'a
dit Madame Smith Daniel Smith cette
semaine puis on revient là-dessus
[Musique]
c'est le message que j'ai envoyé Chantal
madame souhaite a dit je veux pas
l'utiliser la loi mais je vais envoyer
un message qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette approche là mais d'abord que c'est
un peu insulté le mouvement
souverainiste québécois qui a toujours
été plutôt sérieux que de comparer ce
qui se passe à quoi que ce soit quand
gouvernement souverainiste t'aurait fait
au Québec
deuxièmement on a découvert cette
semaine que ou bien madame Smith et son
cabinet
comprennent pas la constitution ou bien
ils l'ont jamais lu parce que le projet
de loi ça fasse même
une législature provinciale quelle
qu'elle soit ne peut pas changer la
répartition des pouvoirs tel que
prescrits dans la Constitution
canadienne en passant un projet de loi
alors ça c'est l'autre problème et on a
découvert en plus au fil des jours que
les ministres de Madame Smith certains
de ces principaux ministres sans doute
trouver ça trop compliqué de lire les 12
pages du projet de loi de son
gouvernement
et donc ça fait pas et elles n'ont plus
de quoi il parlait le résultat c'est que
en Alberta ça a été assez mal reçu merci
commentateur milieu d'affaires
universitaire et Justin Trudeau dont on
inspirait beaucoup maintenant on
souhaitait que c'était et en disant je
vais pour prendre ce projet de loi
clairement il va attendre que les
élections du printemps passent en
Alberto avant de décider s'il y a
quelque chose à faire et clairement
c'était pas le souhait du gouvernement
Bertin qui voulait faire sa campagne en
disant nous sommes votre rempart contre
le méchant Justin Trudeau un échange
cintreau a décidé de s'occuper de
d'autres choses
cette semaine et il a même dit la
première réaction ça a été voyons voir
ce que les Albertins vont dire là-dessus
puis ils étaient éloignés voulait pas
toucher à ça du tout du tout du tout
et pourquoi il y aurait-il toucher pour
faire plaisir à Madame écoutez moi ça
m'a fait penser beaucoup au projet de
loi 99 que le Parti québécois alors au
pouvoir avait fait passer à réponse au
plan B
Ottawa et en disant bon 50 + 1 c'est la
bonne chose nous avons tous les droits
de poser la question référendaire qu'on
veut etc
le gouvernement fédéral avait justement
pas appeler ça un appel et à la fin même
tout le monde s'est satisfait du
jugement de la Cour d'appel pour pas
aller en cours suprême alors un moment
donné si vous voulez provoquer quelqu'un
il faut être sûr qu'il va répondre à
provocation c'est ce qui est pas arrivé
pour la loi 99 c'est ce qui est pas
arrivé pour un projet de loi de de
l'Alberta ce qui est ce qui est un peu
étrange c'est de voir les pékistes dire
ah ben vous voyez ça c'est une bonne
idée peut-être qu'on pourrait regarder
ça nous autres bon les mouvements
souveraineté Chantal le dire toujours
fait très attention de faire des choses
dans la légalité il devrait rester dans
cette ligue là avec un groupe qu'on a
pas entendu beaucoup cette semaine les
conservateurs fédéraux qui mon dieu
regrettez pas devant les caméras quand
on voulait leur poser des questions
là-dessus c'est un peu
non seulement c'est la même famille mais
ils se disent bon Dieu est-ce que je
vois vivre avec d'autres gars comme
celle-là du côté de Pierre pollière va
encore prendre bien des mois parce que
ça sentait ça sentait le mauvais calcul
politique écouter
Michel dise avec raison on voulait
provoquer Ottawa on a mal lu ce qui
s'est passé depuis plusieurs années
Ottawa juste ne pas mordu sur la loi 21
ne pas mordu sur la loi 96 sur la charte
la langue française c'est à dire que il
dit qu'ici oppose va peut-être
intervenir devant les tribunaux
éventuellement mais on n'est pas parti
en guerre contre Québec sur des sujets
très délicats identitaire où on espérait
un peu à Québec de pouvoir casser du
sucre sur le dos d'Ottawa on l'a pas
fait à Ottawa on avait pas le goût de
jouer dans ce film là même chose avec
avec dans d'autres situations alors on a
très très mal jugé de la stratégie de
Justin Trudeau dans les dernières années
et si on manque autant de jugement d'un
point de vue politique je parle même pas
de la légalité de la du projet de loi
selon autant manqué de jugement sur le
point politique c'est sûr que puis à
poilief de se demander qu'est-ce qui
reste en réserve à Daniel Smith et c'est
pas bon
effectivement Chantal rapidement
surtout avec la démission comme par
hasard de Jason Canet dans les minutes
qui ont suivi le dépôt du projet de loi
sur lequel il y a déjà fait savoir tout
le mal qui pensait je pense que la
chèvre de position officielle madame
notele l'ancienne Première ministre
démocrate pourrai pas dire pire sur ce
projet de loi que ce que Jason Kenny a
déjà dit ça envoie un viendroule de
message effectivement élection printemps
d'albertin faut-il le rappeler Alex
Chantal Michel merci beaucoup et à la
semaine prochaine en personne pour le
bilan